*fischia*
*musica tragica*
*urla* strazzianti
*urla*
oddio quello e sangue
mi sento male aiuto
ma porco di quello ****** maledetto
*****
effettivamente ho preso una bella botta guarda quanto sangue mi esce...
ma per fortuna ho tutto cio che mi occorre
disinfettante, la garza e lo scotch
in tessuto veligato e i cerotti, mettiamoci all'opera dai
*urlo sdridente*
mi sento male
malee
faccia triste
cosa sara mai un unghio rotto
un po di colla ed e come nuovo fossero questi problemi della vita
*ispira* MALEDETTO
SPIGOLO DI MERDA
*spacca*
*saltella*
sant'antonio aiutami tu
non pensavo venisse cosi
118 emergenza sto morendo
eccoci arrivati alla fine del video
sono covvinta
che tutti voi hanno reagito in uno di questi
modi
scrivetemi un commento qui sotto di come reagite solitamente
quando vi fate male
ricordati di iscrivervi al canale
e di attivare la campanella vicino al tasto di iscrizione
per rimanere aggiornati su tutti i miei video e ricordatevi di seguirmi su
tutti gli altri social
facebook, musically' e istagram
ADOROHHHH